[Music]
how are you greeted by cristian casará if
he suffers information from news now in
spanish starting today where there will be
changes in the kobe 19 test centers
that includes timetables and even in
some places you will have to present
proof of insurance very important to
mention that  you won't have to pay if you do
n't have insurance visit news now
dotcom
for more information well let me tell you
that the immigrant's house will hold
a virtual workshop today to educate the
community about being here the organization
reported an increase in applications for
the federal program that protects
undocumented youth from deportation
visit and news now dotcom to get
involved
good and police continue to investigate
a shooting in the northeast valley it all
happened near lyon and durango
on sunday afternoon according to reports a
man was transported to the hospital after
being shot  gunshot wound and told
officers he was driving when
someone in another car  he shot him if he has
information about this case he is asked
to call crime stoppers
and in another case the metropolitan police are
still looking for the suspect in a
murder in the east of the valley today this
incident occurred yesterday in quer export
villas near begues valley and mount
storm detectives report that the
victim was shot several times after
a fight
well january is
human trafficking awareness month el mar news iem yesterday
held a forum on the subject and the group
cupcake crowes again launched their
act loco campaign
during the month the  profits from the
sales of some downtown
las vegas businesses will go towards
human trafficking prevention and
victim resources
and now we take a look at the
temperatures in our region
today will be clear with
temperatures reaching almost 70 degrees
there will be an unusual increase during the
week with days looking like
spring season but the cold will return by
the end of  This is how we finish this week this
brief information from News Now in Spanish
I am Cristian Cásseres Happy Monday
[Music]